all right candy
yes candy where'd you grow up where are
you from originally originally georgia
what part savannah savannah
and tell me about your family growing up
you had mom and dad
um
yeah
i don't like my parents
why is that
i don't want to talk about them
my childhood is not good
it was a lot of violence and
a lot of abuse and a lot of
nightmares and demons
and it's a very sad place
do you have siblings
yeah i have um
four baby sisters and
two brothers
so a lot of you
i have more than that
how many kids do you have 14
you have 14 kids
how old are you
i'll be 40 uh soon
i'll be 39 this year
14 kids at 39 years old
you've been busy
i became a mom at 13 and i have two sets
of twins as well that helps
yeah that helped and there's i mean
there's a gap in between the older ones
my firstborn and my twins and the
younger ones there's there's a good gap
how many dads
surprisingly
six
five
five
so back to your childhood
the abuse that was going on was
targeted only
mostly you or everybody got their fair
share
i took
the vast majority of it
to protect my mom and my sisters and my
brother
as much as i could
you finished high school
i got my ged and my high school diploma
in prison actually
so
for regular school you went how far
sixth grade
sixth grade
younger than that
fourth grade
i stopped going to school in fourth
grade
what'd you do after you after
stopping school at fourth grade
pretended to do home school
and then i came out here and
i don't know i just
life happened
i just life happened
if your 14 kids how many are you are you
raising any of them all of them
they're with you right now
um they're not with me right now most of
them my youngest three four are my
youngest four are
but the older ones are
with family
where do you stay now
i stay in
kind of the dara heights kind of
inglewood border in between
how are you supporting yourself
hustle
you came to l.a
what age
i was eight
i came with my best friend and her mom
so you left your family
yeah do you talk with your parents at
all
if i ever talk to my dad i hope it's
hang
with him hanging from a tree
and my mom
i don't talk to her either she
she has a new life
i seen both of my parents once since i
left home
but never again
and my mom
i saw my mom when i was 15
and she told me that we could have a
great relationship
and that everything would be okay
that i could move back in with her
everything would be fine
um as long as i
took care of her heroin habit
for her
and i told her to
more or less [ __ ] off and get out of my
life i didn't need her anyways
and i walked away from her
i never seen her
after that
as a young girl how are you supporting
yourself
hustling
so
does that mean prostitution
sometimes
let's just say any means necessary
not limited to and not excluding all
means necessary
what emotional
things do you go through living this
life with the childhood you had
how does it affect you now
nightmares panic attacks
flashbacks
ptsd
high blood pressure
seizures
i have a lot of physical injuries that
will never heal
um
and drugs are helping you with that
i smoke a lot of weed
a lot of weed
like i smoke weed like people smoke
cigarettes
and i drink drinking helps a lot
drinking helps a lot yeah
no harder drugs
when i was younger yeah but i'm
i'm old i'm over that i just want to
smoke weed and be happy
and raise my son
is alcohol
a problem in your life
um
it's a problem when i don't have it
[Music]
did you feel like you were loved in your
childhood
no
i knew i wasn't
i knew from
the earliest i can ever remember i knew
it was
wrong my parents are two people that
should have never ever ever had children
ever
i respect my mom
i respect them for making me
and giving me life
but that's it
they're dead to me
and as
much memories as i can suppress and
erase and
[Music]
get over or process through
is as much
as as many as i can
because at the end of the day
it never goes away
there's always a demon there's always
some a reminder
a
memory a
song is something there's always
something there's always a trigger
excuse me
no i'm okay okay
cares are good they clean you
what's been the best memory of your life
my kids
every day that i wake up knowing that
i'd never be anything like my mom
was to me
and every time one of my kids looks at
me
or they do something cute or they come
home so proud about something at school
those are the best memories i'll ever
have
they're irreplaceable
important to be a good parent
in your kid's lives
i do the best i can are the fathers in
their lives
no
not most of them
really no
two of them
are dead
three of them are dead
one of them
i would shoot myself if i could
and the other two i just don't
we just don't see each other anymore
if we run into each other in passing
like here and there
the commonalities of courtesy yeah but
it doesn't go further than that
my girlfriend is the best
dad that
any of my kids have ever known
what's the background of your
kids fathers are they gangs or
most of well
half of them
yeah most of them
all of them except for one actually
no except for two
yeah there's two of them that were not
in gangs
what are you afraid of now
what do you worry about
what do i worry about
i have a one-year-old baby at home
and i'm sick
and there's no cure for what i have
yet
supposed to say yet
hope and faith in the outrage
can i ask what you have
i have very severe lupus i have both
forms both types
and
i have severe kidney damage because of
that already
[Music]
i also have
they've found
cancer cells in my
ovaries
three different times
and i now have a cyst on one ovary
i'm a walking time bomb
loop lupus deteriorates your body from
the inside out
once your bones are gone and your
muscles are [ __ ] the only thing left
is your organs
so you die from multiple organ failure
and it could happen like
that i could be fine today and wake up
half dead tomorrow
are you in pain
all the time
always
the only treatment is
the only thing that they can offer is
pain management
which is basically let's let us just
turn you into a government funded
heroin addict
better yet let's do you worse we're just
going to
eventually get you on methadone and then
you're going to be doing your own shots
and you're [ __ ] after that
they told me
i can write you a script for morphine
but i can't do anything else really
i can turn you into a junkie but i can't
help you
you've been around before before
you've been in love before i've been in
love before yes of course
and i've been
beyond heartbroken
i'm in love now
who's the father of your one-year-old
no he's dead
he's one of the dead ones
with my girlfriend
we've been together since
my husband died
um
[Music]
my youngest
son's
father he we were married
briefly but we were married
um
when
he got murdered
he had barely came home he just had his
birthday
in june
we found out i was pregnant in july
and
he got murdered in august
when he
got murdered
i couldn't find a reason to want to live
anymore
and then my girlfriend came around
i mean i mean we've known each other for
a long time like
we actually dated like
10 years ago
very briefly
um
but then we kind of went our separate
ways and we seen each other in passing
from time to time
and then i ran into her right after he
got murdered
and
she
is the only reason why i'm alive
she's the only reason besides my kids
that i keep
waking up
it's why i keep
pushing myself harder and
doing things that i know i probably
shouldn't be doing
just to
just to make sure i'm there for them
what are you proudest of in your life
my strength
the fact that i
keep getting smacked in
the face with reality and i keep
i'm still here
i'm still going i'm still
thriving i'm still
working to better myself i'm still
i'm still beating the odds
instead of becoming a statistic
that in my ability to write
i'm very proud of my writings
do you have any regrets in your life
i have things that i could say
i wish could have happened differently
or that i had
maybe went left instead of right
but
me personally i don't see things as
regret because
i can't go back and change it
it's done already so why regret it just
learn from it and do it different
yeah
living like that i get smacked in the
face with
up shit's creaking damned if i do and
damned if i don't all the time
and it hurts but
it only makes me go harder
what would you say is the most important
thing you learn
right now my kids and my girlfriend
and just making getting our home
together
and keeping home no but what would you
say is the most important thing you've
learned in your life oh the most
important thing i've learned um
that you never stop learning
we never stop learning
all right candy thank you so much for
sharing your story you're welcome i wish
you the best of luck with your
lucas and your kids and everything else
thank you thank you very much
you